ich drück dich retten aber mein gott da
denke ich mir so chillig ich schreib
irgendwas nämlich selbst halb tot weil
ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer neuen folge
mein kraft hero es ist hier immer noch
nachts logical geht kann unter wir sind
immer noch hier bei diesem komischen
tower und ich wollte den eigentlich
fertig machen
da waren wir einfach viel zu viel
spinnen und die sind immer noch alle als
dann der untergegangene das war echt
abartig wie viele da waren
ich bin jetzt einfach runter gemacht
dass jetzt einfach mal hier der barbier
natürlich wieder am start
wir haben auf jeden fall richtig viele
geile sachen gefunden gefangen keine
ahnung
in diesen folgen worauf ich richtig
richtig stolz bin also wir haben so viel
wie sind so voll hier das ist richtig
richtig geil
ich habe auch erst mal alles mitgenommen
einfach also wir können danach immer
noch aussortieren dann was den müll
schmeißen was wir halt dann doch nicht
nehmen war da wenn ich diese spinnen
schon den haag irgendwer von euch
spinnen irgendwer von den zuschauern
denn ja verpisst euch vielleicht habt
ihr alle gleich sind solche gekko
salamander besitzende leute hier auch
noch mit am start also keine ahnung wenn
ihr das mögt dann sollt euch wohl ein
herber ich verpasse einfach denn ich
finde es echt das ist auf der welt man
kleine tierchen war die sonne geht auf
freunde wir brauchen auf jeden fall
immer noch sexy carl sachen man müsste
eigentlich unseren shader haben sowohl
so alles schwarz ist nur der mexikaner
sache so beleuchten
das wäre cool sonst aber ich kann auch
gar nicht hier richtig gucken weil hier
alles okay ist
mit dem schild das echt kacke weihnacht
macht ihr jetzt mal kurz raus kommen
damit wir sehen dies ohne stadt wäre da
schon relativ hallo
ja ich mache jetzt mal ohne schilder
wenn wir zu weihnachten weihnacht ist
jetzt mal ohne schäden am tag wieder
dahin
es wird der tag von jackies widerhall
von verrechnen wir brauchen menschen wie
sind denn die keine das kann nicht sein
dass die überall schon welche waren oder
wie java zu bild.de zu sehen
da hab ich nicht
seit beginn ist hier nicht irgendwo habe
ich nicht hier irgendwo ist hier nicht
ist dir dein war 3 ist da nicht irgendwo
habe ich dann gesagt dass dann
reingepackt das ist in der anderen
tasche quasi hier drin sein
ja er liebt mich mein schoko pro liter
milch mobil auf eigentlich gerade her
was ist das hier für das sehr cool wenn
es um das wecken von biomet wo es so nur
hexe kahles nutzen wir mit lucas exit
welt einfach nur existenzen überall aber
das so packe dass ich mich suchen muss
vielleicht kann der mir hinten damit
abgeben oder so falls er so nett dass er
mich töten will ich weiß nicht wo da
wird was cooles kommen am 24
also morgen geben luca hat eine externe
das war mein großer wunsch weil man 2006
egal essenzen live dabei und hier das
sind auch die lieder die wir dann immer
zu weihnachten dingen
wer daran glaube ich damit ja ich glaube
ich habe fünf oder sechs und ich brauche
noch ein bisschen also diese folgen
alleine weil gott verdammt langweilig
eigentlich war ich das im livestream
machen aber ich krieg zeit einfach nicht
geschissen mit openbroadcast da
irgendwie zu streamen weil es halt mega
lag die ganze zeit mattes streams fest
streams ob das alles bei mir
funktioniert dann vor
aber es ist echt immer doof am haken
legen alles einfach alles doof so das
ist eigentlich ein richtig gutes abi
kabine
32 viele meinen auch dass drei kuba
werde bei 3 so aber ich finde eigentlich
bruder war einst die sonne noch so crazy
daisy so das ist ein gutes bier um so
noch existenzen ausschau zu halten
bestimmt schreiben wir diese leute in
die kommentare ja aber das ist dann kann
ich jetzt endlich live sehen
wieder nicht ihr hellseher oder sowas
auch jetzt ist das ja auch wieder vorbei
wow
mega ausbeute richtig geil hallo andi da
hinten geht's weiter
und das ist nur dieses diesel ruins
kacke ich schwimme ohne willst dich
schön wir jetzt eine halbe minute
darüber und wenn dann nicht wenn ich da
nicht irgendwie festland sehen oder so
dann fühle ich mich dabei auch einige
leute so macht doch hier mal dass hier
das ich habe das jetzt übrigens in die
mitte geparkt
aber wenn ich hier doch das ist damit
okay gut damit dass mit der cam besser
war kann ich froh sein dass ich gerade
nicht ein stromkabel rausgerissen ab
heute meinen ganzen pc nach hinten
gezogen ok jetzt ist die karte einfach
komplett weg oder geht's hoch
yahoo ok ich gebe jetzt noch eine halbe
minute wenn man da nicht irgendwie land
ist oder so ich aber echt traurig also
tokio jockey du kannst natürlich nichts
dafür
die zurück suchen
ich weiß nicht mehr genau man mit der
karte um gmbh beraten nein die
veröffentlichung sei ich bin schneller
als die ja sonst würde ich sagen muss
ich mich jetzt ja das ist kacke dass ich
auf ski unterwegs bin auf dem trikot
kommt dass damit scheiße kommt das dann
mit
ich hätte vielleicht nicht mit dem zug
unterwegs sein sollen
ach du scheiße sagt man was mach ich
denn jetzt
er konnte das tobit wenn ich die höhe
ich hab keine ahnung ich habe ein
bisschen angst wenn ich dann gleich
dieses ich kann auch gar nicht den
spiegel benutzen weil wir hier keine ort
noch festland beim euro festland also
richtiges festland glaube ich richtiges
festland ich kann den spiegel glaube ich
ja gar nicht benutzen
scheiße daran habe ich jetzt gar nicht
gedacht
das blöde festung existenz ich gehe
jetzt mal eben rein aber organ scheiße
also ich werde auf jeden fall den
spiegel benutzen während ich auf cheeky
drauf sitze ich muss erst mal ich habe
fünf electric ist enzen da wieder h
wir können uns milliarden stars machen
markiert sondern jetzt ich fliege jetzt
einfach mal nach oben
kommt sie in los angeles
paketbombe
danke danke und traden
kg wird geht bei euch
kommt es wenn nicht wenn diego kommt
muss gar nicht unterkommen
erstmalig kann man klettern erfolg nur
die sind nicht stark aber die nerven
tatsachen geschaffen mit dem shaker ist
das ein bisschen durchzuschlagen
ich nehme das man trotzdem mit ihr so
kobald und co
hallo das gilt ja oder ich mache das
einfach in der nächsten folge dann frage
ich mal den er wegen den magic mirror
weil ich nicht dass ich dann einfach
irgendwas falsch mache dass es
vielleicht doch mit jockey geht
es ist heftig bin nur noch am kämpfen
hier diese ganzen blöden festung
fühlst du dich du bist echt so einer
den muss man ab und zu boxen damit er
wieder ein bisschen an ihren krieg das
passt schon mal unten das unten kommt
hier kurz
so habe ich hier wie einfach töten
shuffles lane bei pirate hooker ich kann
dich nicht ich kann ihn nicht retten was
ich schreib das gleich mal ich glücklich
retten aber oh mein gott da denke ich
mir so viel ich schreibe ihnen was
nämlich selbst halb tot
oha war das gras alter stelle ich mir
vor ich wäre auch gestorben dann
geschafft und bei youtube kann ich auch
toll ich würd ich würde dich retten aber
kann nicht
altona mich selber fast tot oha das war
gerade im moment wo man sich noch so
denkt so habe das heftig hilft club so
schnell wieder so viel kaffee dabei wie
gesagt ich packe das hier erst mal alles
fein
man muss echt denn wenn ich besondere
reise hier muss man so viele sachen
mitnehmen also für rucksäcke
oha also das war gar nichts die haben
halt ein selber getötet
das war gar nicht so nah an dem punkt wo
ich mir gedacht habe scheiße das erste
mal so wieder nach ein paar folgen jetzt
packe ich könnte sterben obwohl ich
eigentlich mittlerweile echt finde wenn
ich zu hause bin und dann mal die ganze
sache hier so auswerte was sich so alles
hab und die kacke wegschmeißen wie werde
ich mir echt ein paar geile sache machen
können weil ich bin echt meine freunde
ich bin jetzt level 3
damit kann man so ein paar geile sachen
auf jeden fall auf die rüstung
verzaubern bei euch hassen es wenn ich
herzen schwarz sind
es ist einfach dass man richtig angst
man im moment tot ist
alter war das gerade heftig oha was hat
dich da angst aber verständlich auch
oral war das heftig wie viele mops hier
allgemein sind auf dieser bullischen
blöden plattform aber das wäre die beste
sache die in die kommentare gießen hat
packt ihn findet ihr auf seinen bogen
wieso bin ich da eigentlich nicht selbst
drauf gekommen weil eine ganze weile weg
um das kleine pfeile werfen ist einfach
nur sieben erfahrungspunkte aber ich
weiß nicht was mir dann verzaubert soll
ich denn die tief aber machen wer die
fifa mal an verzaubern
das ist ganz neues schaffen es immer
noch ihr alter jetzt nur noch auf die
server der es ist also immer noch ein
todes screen das eigentlich alles fertig
haben und zu hause seine fonds nach wird
er mich an ich kann ihn nicht geschafft
ist
freunde alter diese da jetzt werde ich
dachte da kommt doch aus der jacke und
dessen britische firma gutbrod electric
ist setzen wir haben nicht 14 minuten
sind auch schon wieder
dann mache ich es entweder am anfang der
folge mit dene und mit zug oder auf eine
andere möglichkeit ausprobieren geht ja
eigentlich nicht
die zahl noch ein stark von mama papa
und herausgenommen ja ich glaube an sich
was ist eigentlich mit dem heftigen lud
das ist egal
sonst hab ich habe angst alter
ich hoffe es kommt jetzt von hinten über
wenn ich schieße kommt ihm die rechts
und feinden ich weiß gar nicht warum
vor allem ich war da nicht mal bei der
seite 5 wo alle tot vor leute einfach
nur essenzen und kämpfe pur wieder oha
auf einmal kommen wir einfach so zehn
millionen leute an
da dachte ich schon wieder ich werde
sie fordern
so dass nichts ich bin 45 das ist mir
gut ich will jetzt eigentlich das hier
eben noch beenden und dann nach hause
schnell dann kann ich vielleicht sogar
schon ein bisschen sortieren der sich
als ein paar sachen kann ihn ja etwas
rein
ich höre böse leute waren bilder leiter
2 beta leute alle müssen sterben so lauf
gerade einfach nur irgendwie rum oder
oder laufe ich laufe ich eigentlich auch
mal immer nach unten statt 1 müsste ich
eigentlich gar nicht einfach direkt vor
mich stellen verschießen
das hier unverschämt diese leute sind
die höchsten von allen herzlich
täglich folgeschaden als chisora gerade
ich habe keins geschossen
oha dann war er war deswegen so komisch
also so komisch gelähmt oder durch mir
das nur eingebildet alles komme ich
verwenden
ich will eigentlich noch gar nicht
wieder runter
aber nicht cactus claude kaktus kacke
kaktus kacke luca du bist du willst dir
und euch jetzt mal bitte was ist
eigentlich mit dem eis euro wenn ich den
jetzt irgendwie so hab hab ich davon
dann auch unendlich quasi beim schießen
komme ich gehe wenn die fackeln alle
sind eine kiste
bilder peter hier wieder am start tot
ich kriege noch immer so ein bisschen
gold das ist auch ganz schön eigentlich
muss man meinen
little giants portner reparieren da ist
nichts mehr
aber wir sind auch schon wieder fast und
nähe das ist ja noch eine tasche wir
sind in so einer heftigen gefängnis ja
gerade darin nach komme ich jetzt keinen
bock mehr habe zeige ich gesagt wenn die
fackeln alle sind aber das ist nicht so
bin ich halt damit muss ich noch da
rostock ii ich musste ich komme da von
neuer da ist ja gut freunde ich probiere
das jetzt eben noch nach hause zu kommen
mit jockey zusammenhalt der schaufel
die müssen irgendwo hin wo etwas über
uns ist
egal doch ich hab doch eine schaufel
irgendwo der schaufel läuft doch ich
hoffe dass das jetzt funktioniert wenn
es nicht funktioniert jetzt echt mega
freien fall
aber ich werde bald mit dass wir mit der
fackel los ich werde bald zum bay
aufnehmen und dann meinte er dass ich
dann meinen killer dingsbums bekomme so
ein goldenes chocobo 19 minuten 40 oha
jetzt will ich das jetzt nicht schaffe
zurückzukommen
das wäre so bitter also wenn ich etwas
verkackt 100 bin ich quasi gefangen da
muss ich am nächsten folgerichtig fiel
zurück laufen aber freundlich hoffe dass
es nicht funktioniert und ich hoffe dass
es funktioniert also dass es nicht so
ist
so hier runter so es ist jetzt was über
mir jetzt mal ganz kurz
so kommen wir können jetzt nur beten
dass es funktioniert bitte bitte bitte
bitte bitte
es ging nicht mit youtube
auch man verdammt scheiß dich mal follow
gemacht verdammt warum fällt mir das
denn jetzt der 1
auch ich bin da tappen es spaß die
online das kann nicht wahr sein was eine
kappe wieder eine tür ich bitte darum
dass ihr auflegt ja gut in der nächsten
folge werde ich dann ein bisschen
sortieren hier freunde da egal wenn es
euch gefallen hat wir haben so was von
viel geschafft wir haben so eine geile
ausbeute ist der andere rucksack also
unsere ausbeute ist echt das hier
und das hier komplett voll da sind
richtig geile sachen weil wir haben
batterie sind in zwei electric essenzen
hier sind drei also wir haben fünf
electric ge stensen oder hier vielleicht
sogar noch welche fünf electric essenzen
sind noch welche ich glaube ich 95 doch
hier seinen rucksack
hier sind
auch keine regal m5 vielleicht regis
tänzen wir haben mega geile sachen wie
im winter dafür haben cloud wut des
cloud boots machen zeige ich euch mal
eben ganz kurz das machen cloud gut
seitlich ganz nice und sonst welche dann
in der nächsten folge mit denen meine
sachen sortieren
meine sachen einräumen die rüstung
verzaubern dann schon die ersten teile
von der fifa machen und eventuell bei
denen ein bisschen schmoren
und dann will ich sagen eurovision
überzogen wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lasst eine bewertung da und wir sehen
beim nächsten mal wieder als gut